it's great to be a thanks very much for
coming on today I'm gonna be talking
about visualizing enterprise data with
d3 it says enterprise in the title but
really it's about adding visualizations
to any significant data set really more
than a hundred rows a hundred records in
your data set you may want to consider
adding visualizations I'm using d3 it's
an awesome library of talks kind of
broken up into two rough halves the
first half is demonstrating and
explaining why I think visualizations
are great why you should be adding them
to your applications if you can how they
add value and the second half is just
how you can ramp up with d3 d3 is a
powerful library it's got a huge amount
of potential and power after the talk
I'd encourage you to go check out the
gallery these just about every sort of
graph and visualization available for
any use case the problem with these
three can be it has a fairly steep
learning curve so the second the second
half of the talk is just to give you an
introduction into the main entry points
of how to get going with d3 so there's
two two rough halves yeah so
increasingly us as developers depending
on which industry in which area we work
on are facing larger and larger datasets
right and that's only set to grow
regardless of what industry you're in if
you financial or medical or social media
the data we're getting is ever
increasing and that's hugely valuable
we've got to can do so much with this
information specifically things like
medical data what insights and
breakthroughs are we going to break make
with the huge amounts of data we're able
to gather the problem is that large data
is hard it's not impossible to
understand if you're looking at a
hundred rows of data for example it can
be hard to digest if you're looking at
million rows well it's almost impossible
so data is king it's absolutely king and
we need to look
at the underlying data often I am I most
of my background is from a financial
background where it's not only important
for the user to confirm that the
decision they're about to make for a
trade for a loan for a mortgage is based
on actual accurate data so they need to
look at that data and it's often a
regulatory requirement depending on your
industry to display that data as well so
that's great and it's important that's
not going to change but I think we can
add a lot more value to our users and
allow them to get insights that would be
much harder otherwise with
visualizations humans are very visual
animals we've evolved over you know
thousands of hundreds of years thousands
years to gain insights quickly often
rapidly and my favorite example of that
are road signs we're able to gain at a
glance often while moving at speed
useful and critical information in just
one picture so I think we can probably
take that concept and translate it and
copy it over to whatever application or
sphere we're working in so that's the
aim of this talk the first half anyway
to convince you want to encourage you to
add visualizations if you can if it
makes sense for your domain and if
you're not already doing so so the data
set we're going to look at as an example
is an Olympic information its Olympic
data sets of all medals won by all
athletes from 2000 to 2012 it's a simple
data set I didn't want to get something
that you know we would struggle to
understand before we could understand
what I was trying to illustrate so this
is fairly simple per row we've got who
won how old they were what they want and
what medals they won and see if we can
derive any insights from this data set
so we'll switch over so I'm using a grid
yeah as you hopefully you can see that
yep so we can already see it's already
ordered by total medals one we can see
Michael Phelps has won a fairly
significant number of medals just in
those three years and that's that's fine
so at a glance we can see that Michael
Phelps looks like he's on
but let's assume let's pretend there's
some other asset who had one not so many
in one year but many many men sorry many
medals over many years it wouldn't
necessarily be easy to derive the same
information you'd still think this is
maybe that Michael Phelps was up top so
let's see if we can get some more
information from that so let's let's
group this by athletes so Malik Michael
Phelps still looks like he's on top and
that's groupid by aggregate by total
medals one so that's great right we've
already gone a step further we can
confirm that as far as total medals one
Michael Phelps is by far and ahead away
in in the lead 22 total medals we don't
know what sorts of medals we can expand
that and go further but already we're
able to derive something so that's
useful right but it's already required a
few clicks few drags we could get the
setup up front but still it's it can be
difficult so this grouped by country
let's use one of the most medals and so
from this we can so the US United States
is ahead by some way Russia second
Germany Australia third and China and
then it tails off so that's useful right
we I guess we could have guessed that
but it's clear already from this that
the United States is ahead but that
doesn't tell us how they're ahead that
doesn't tell us which sports they're
heading did they win more bronzes than
gold and everyone else what's the
proportion we can get that information
from here we can always derive the
insights we can gain more visualizations
from the raw data but it's much easier
and it's much less resource-intensive
mentally resource intensive if we can
derive that information at a glance so
let's take a look at how we can do that
so when I say visualizations what do I
mean well visualization is the process
of translating raw quantitative
information into graphical
representation and what I mean by that
is just taking data and put it into
visualization or pictorial formats it
helps in my opinion
your users to interpret their data and
visualization will as I hopefully
demonstrate in a minutes will help your
users find insight in noise so the
application that I've put together for
this is going to have two halves on the
left side we're gonna have a grid
component with a raw data so we can
confirm what we're seeing and then the
right side will have some visualization
that goes along with the selected data
and what we're doing is that to see if
we can get a better idea of what we're
looking at the applications pretty
simple I won't spend too much time on
this we've got a grid components that's
responsible for managing the grid for
displaying the data the configuration
what we do when we click on rows we've
got a little chart data service that
will interact with the chart service on
the right and the grid components also
responsible for switching out the chart
component depending on what the users
asking it to do it's pretty simple
application and the code will be
available after the talk but that's not
a focus of the talk so we'll go on to
the actual application so i've
pre-wrapped
pre can wrapped three types of
visualizations we can do at this data so
we already think and we already know
that the US Russia Australia China ahead
in terms of medals one let's see if we
can dig down to that dig a little deeper
so this group selects the top ten
countries by total medals one right so
we're not looking at the types of medals
building a golden silver and bronze
we're just looking at the total counts
so we click on that hopefully you can
see that so if you can't see the label
at the bottom at the back it's got on
the Left United States Russia Germany
Australia China and then Canada and
trailing off so that confirms what we've
seen earlier but what I like about this
starting point is visually we don't have
to use too much energy to work out that
the United States is by far and away the
winner here in in terms of total medals
won almost just just under double Russia
looks like maybe just double
in Australia so it's the same
information we got before but we're able
to derive that information within maybe
two seconds maybe three maybe more but
ultimately we are able to derive a huge
amount of information which we were able
to derive before but a lot less can in
horizontally and vertically we can just
glance at the picture look at the labels
and go yep United States is by far in
terms of total medals one the number one
winner so let's see if we can take that
a step further let's see if we can
derive a little bit more information
from the data set we're looking at so we
did the same thing but now we're
breaking it down by total led by the
middle types and what I like about this
one I think this is my favorite one is
that it it puts a distance between the
United States and the rest that isn't
necessarily obvious from the raw data
and grouping and aggregation or even the
first visualization so looking at this
you can see that the bronze is about on
par with Russia Silver's are about
double Russia and the other countries
but gold is almost triple everyone else
so not only are the United States ahead
in overall they are ahead by some way in
gold and silver and about on par with
bronze that's a huge amounts of
information that we were able to derive
in almost no time and almost no effort
right as developers we had to put a bit
of effort to do this but you're a user
by clicking on a button and selecting
the information they're after is able to
derive a huge amounts of information
just by having a visualization to go
alongside their raw data now imagine
taking this translating this to a much
richer data set maybe we're looking at
social media and we will then look at
trends complicated trends maybe not easy
trends medical the rate data we want to
see where hotspots are for certain
diseases and maybe why those diseases
are occurring visualizations would help
with that enormous Lee the last
visualization is little simple and the
colors are terrible I apologize for that
it really confirms what we've seen here
we're looking at the top 10 for
athletics again the United States and
Russia are number one and then what's
interesting about this one though is
that in terms of population Jamaica and
Ethiopia
in the top 10 by a significant margin
and given their population count
relative to United States and Russia we
can really see that they punch in far
above their weights in terms of
population right so although not as I
think impactful is the second
visualization this is telling us
something it's telling us that US and
Russia are ahead that's great but in
terms of population much smaller
countries are doing really well in
athletics and that's just what one
little chart that's great and so
hopefully illustrates the point I'm
trying to make so that's the first half
I encourage you to check out the three
the visualizations from what the options
are the second part of the talk is just
to dig into these three a bit when I
started d3 a little bit overwhelmed the
documentation is great and it's there
but it's definitely not geared towards
beginners so the rest of this talk is
just the basics of d3 and how you can
get started with it and the concepts so
we'll start off with selection like
jQuery d3 allows for selection of
existing Dom elements so a little bit a
little bit of HTML two tops just to set
up a starting points which I'll demo in
the in a minute so we've got a row with
a number of circles within and the d3
code is at the bottom so we've got some
data we've got five datum items there
and we're gonna use these three to
select all circles and associate data
with it okay so if we go look at that
we'll see that these three is actually
doing something with us that's how the
code looks as it is and we've run the
code and d3 hopefully you can read that
so I'll pull it up those at the back so
these trees the HTML was rendered these
three hasn't changed what we have seen
but it has dumped something in the
background so let's look at the first
item the first circle on the Left if we
select it I've given an ID so we can
select it and we go right down to the
bottom hopefully you can see that maybe
you can't it's added at eight attributes
called underscore underscore data and
the score underscore and giving it a
value of two and the second circle will
have a value of four and the second one
six and so on so what these three is
done with selection is the first thing
has done is found all existing Dom items
we've said it asked it to select and
associated the data we've asked it to
associate with it we can expand on that
just to confirm what I'm saying
so we've iterated all the circles and
iterate them out put the data item and
hopefully you can see it is 2 4 6 8 so
each of those circles has a data item
the data we've given it associated it to
it and that's important because
subsequent steps to manipulate these Dom
items will use the data we've associated
with it if you may have noticed that
we've got five data items but only four
circles we'll come back to that in a
minute so let's put that away so the
second step here is to beg your pardon
okay so we've selected it the second
step will be to min start manipulating
the existing items so I'll show you the
code in a minute because that was quite
quickly that's on the slide what we've
done is use the items we've associated
with the Dom items and scaled it so for
example - we've timed it by a value for
we've time to evaluate in size so this
is this is I guess d3 101 select Dom
items manipulate the Dom items with the
data and so let's go take a look at what
we did there so in the second step we've
selected as we did before we selected
the circles we associated data with it
and then we've changed the style of the
Dom items so for each item to d3 like
jQuery allows chaining of items and we
also d3 starts at the top left and draws
down and to the right so we'll change
the height according to the data item
and the width according to the data item
so the circles get bigger they depend on
the size of the data and at the bottom
we've manipulated the margin so that as
humans we expect the graph and
visualizations get from bottom up so we
just pushed the margin top down
and allow for the data so if we started
at the bottom and scrolled up we
wouldn't have to do that but because d3
like most graph and libraries start at
the top and scroll down we just
manipulate the library so you can
actually inline this a bit more I'm just
I've just broken the mountains is for
different points just to illustrate
which each items doing so for each data
item we're doing manipulating one
attribute of the style so moving on to
that's selection and manipulating items
and that's great for when you want to
manipulate existing Dom items as I said
before we've got five datum items but we
only have four existing images this
brings us to the second concepts or d3
concept that I wanted to introduce and
that's the enter selection on the Left
we have existing arts items that's
selection on the right we then add new
items using the enter method so you'll
see how we've got four existing items
the fourth one at the fifth one ten will
be I added by us you add in enter and
then manipulate in the DOM item so the
top half of this code is the code we've
already seen and in the bottom half
although we could chain this I've broken
it up into separate items to make it
care we've used Enter so this says
everything that's not already associated
do this with it so for every item that
we not associated we add a div and then
we associate the attributes as we did
before so this is going to add a fifth
circle with a height with border radius
as before and add it to our application
so let's take a look at that as I said
you can chain these and you can make it
in line but for demonstration purposes I
want to make it clearer so for items
with the fifth circle added so selection
for existing Dom items enter for new Dom
items it's pretty simple it's just not
always clear from the d3 documentation
demos what these things are actually
doing the last three items I want to
touch on are scales and these are how
you want to scale your data both
horizontally and vertically depending on
your data
for example if you've got 2 4 6 8 10 but
you actually want to fill up your screen
with a thousand pixels horizontally and
800 pixels you need to add scales or if
you want to use dates and that's where
scales will come in so I'm gonna touch
on through these many types of scales
but the three main scales you're likely
to use
I'll cover here the first one is an
ordinal scale so as it says an ordinal
scale mapped discrete values in an array
to discrete values and values in an
array so for example if we had RGB our
data so 2 4 6 we want to map it to RGB
that's what we'd use here so I create an
ordinal scale I set my domain which is
my data and I want the output for our to
be a red G for green B for blue and then
when we call ordinal scale when we
manipulate and on items it'll return the
associated items so if ordinal scale of
our will turn red so a discrete value to
a discrete value it's pretty simple I
think the second one is band scales
which is similar to ordinal but it's a
continuous range instead of a discrete
value to a discrete value we're going
from a discrete value to an item on a
range so as before we've got RGB as our
data but that's gonna scale between 0
and 200 and so our is 0 G is 66 about
halfway I guess and B is 133 and it'll
leap over so if we do it again it'll go
over to 0 so that's more useful when you
want a continuous scale and lastly the
linear scale this is the one you'll
probably use most often you'll use it
when you want a continuous domain
numbers dates for example 4 so for
example and typically this will be your
y-axis so you've got a set amounts of
data items but you want to scale it
horizontally you'll use a linear scale
for that so yeah we've got we create a
linear scale we set our domain which is
0 and 10 so that's how data items so the
start and the max of our data items the
range will go from zero to a thousand
and we want to scale that continuously
on our range so zero is
two point five as you'd expect given the
numbers would be 257 would be 700 and
obviously ten would be a thousand so
it's for mapping items items that's are
smaller or bigger than you want to
render on your screen and scaling them
onto a screen I hope that makes sense
those are the three main scales I would
like to have gone into this bit further
but time constraints hopefully that
gives you an introduction into d3
hopefully that introduces you to the
scales the three scales you're likely to
use and encourages you to go check out
d3 it's got a huge amount of
visualizations more than I could
probably describe here everything that
you're likely to encounter but all of
those visualizations use the concepts
I've described so if you're not using
visualizations and it makes sense for
your domain consider adding them your
users will thank you they'll get so much
more information than they would
otherwise just from the raw data thank
you very much